back to the G in Freemasonry that's
generative principle like Sigman Freud
talked about all Sexual Energy
everything comes from Sexual Energy and
the more I read about this stuff they
would on certain zodiac alignment dates
this is how Egyptians would do it they
would wait till like the clock strikes
at 8:00 p.m. on a certain date to have
that electric etheric orgasm with their
partner to manifest wealth so they'll
choose on a day like eight eight is the
money frequency and I was like what the
[__] all sex is ritualistic that makes
way more sense than what I'm taught in
high school which is in high school they
just say sex is like a handshake save it
for marriage but it's just no sex is
like this is why people get jealous and
stab each other for just like some one
night hoe is like there's it's like a
soul TI